because we saw the video how big these
shrimps can be kind of fit in your hand
almost tell us about the scale of this
project bill how big is it yeah other
than the the shrimp Yvonne by any
measure this is an incredibly ambitious
project as you said it's going to be the
biggest in the developed world and if it
was a country this project alone would
be the the seventh largest producer of
prawns it's set on a site about the size
of Disney World in Florida and in a very
remote
patch of northern Australia and it's
certainly Australia's most ambitious
attempt to industrialize prawn
production I love her so the quotes that
you have in your story supercharging
natural selection and kiss so how is
this all going to come together that's
right but that's a key element of this
before they can produce the prawns grow
the prawns if you like in those ponds in
northern Australia scientists have first
got to unlock the genome of the black
tiger prawn they haven't done that
before and then they've got to select
the traits that they want in this super
prawn to breed for and then you know
even before they even before they can
sell them they need funds for this
project it's beyond the scope of the the
shrimp farmer to fund this project that
sea farms group which is a Sydney listed
company so they need foreign investment
before they can sell the first prawn
sometime in 2018 at the earliest yeah
you know it's a similar thing that
they've actually done I guess you could
say with chickens cows but with shrimp
this is something that's relatively new
as well so you know you talked about the
tiger shrimp tell us about this super
shrimp then yeah this super shrimp this
is really fascinating I mean the the the
genome of the black tiger prawn is ten
times more complicated than the human
genome so you know once they once they
unlock that then they've got to breed
this super shrimp for sale and it's as
you say it's got to grow faster than
normal shrimps they're been looking to
accelerate growth rates perhaps double
them in six or seven years it's got to
look tasty so when it's cooked it's got
to have that
two pink tone if you like and it's also
got to have high levels of omega-3 fats
so all in all this is something that's
never been achieved in the wild
centuries of natural evolution have
failed and scientists are trying to
replicate this in just a few years so
it'd be fascinating to see if they
succeed